this video was brought to you by
betterhelp
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everybody Helen here with some
thoughts about stranger things the
content overlords at Netflix finally
dropped the end of season four and
according to popular opinion The Duffer
Brothers stuck The Landing but while the
show has been praised from maturing with
season four it hasn't completely shaken
criticism that it relies too heavily on
Nostalgia some see it as little more
than a gumbo of references aimed at
grown-up 80s kids but in recent Seasons
it's introduced plot points that
confront the darker side of the 1980s
and nostalgia in general choosing to
actually examine the past instead of
just serving up more of the warm and
fuzzy Nostalgia we've come to expect and
yet these two approaches the comforting
and the critical are also diametrically
opposed which makes us Wonder can
stranger things subvert the very
Nostalgia it also evokes let's take a
look in this wisecrack Edition can
stranger things Nostalgia grow up and
spoilers ahead but before we dive in we
want to thank this video's sponsor
betterhelp if you've been feeling
anxious overwhelmed or depressed lately
Better Health can be an excellent
resource to help you feel better I
personally can't remember a time when I
didn't feel anxious are overwhelmed and
the constant barrage of bad news that
seems to come every minute of every hour
of every day now isn't making it easier
but thankfully there are resources out
there better helps network of more than
20 000 therapists are ready to listen
and support you after completing a short
questionnaire you'll be matched with a
therapist whose expertise fits your
unique needs and what's so great about
betterhelp where everything is done
remotely is that you can work with a
therapist whose skills might not
otherwise be available in your area
within 48 hours you can start messaging
your therapist at any time when you do
reach out you'll receive timely and
thoughtful responses in return
Additionally you can schedule your
choice of secure phone or video sessions
to receive Counseling in real time in my
case I had my first session with Sarah
scheduled three days after matching with
her and honestly it was one of the best
therapy experiences that I've ever had
she was so nice so empathetic and so
knowledgeable and I left with tools that
I can use to help myself when I'm
feeling super anxious and if you and
your therapist aren't a perfect match
it's easy and free to switch to a new
one so join the more than 2 million
people who have taken in charge of their
Mental Health Health with better help by
visiting betterhelp.com wisecrack or
just click the link in the video
description when you do you'll get 10
off your first month that's better
help.com wisecrack and now back to the
Show Now The Duffer Brothers have been
open about how much they're borrowing
from the films of yesteryear
specifically Steven Spielberg's and
they're not subtle stranger things has
been filled with references to 1980s
movies from the jump and as always shown
just how saturated the kids are in the
decades pop culture what if the bad
people kidnapped her what they're
forcing her to say this
Lando Calrissian don't answer stranger
things is hardly the first TV show to
Peddle in Nostalgia but its salience
today may be indicative of our times
Scholars fed Lana Boyne calls Nostalgia
an incurable modern condition describing
its ubiquity as a defense mechanism in a
time of accelerated rhythms of life and
historical upheavals that is to say when
our world is changing and the present
feels precarious like
um right this [ __ ] second we
collectively experience what Boyne
describes as a yearning for a different
time the time of our childhood the
slower rhythms of our dreams she noted
way back in 2001 that American culture
was becoming increasingly
self-referential as it sought Solas in a
simpler past while the prevalence of
nostalgia content makes sense many
remain skeptical about how stranger
things uses it early on the New York
Times labeled stranger things as 80s
karaoke and while that's pretty harsh
especially if Don't Stop Believin is
your showstopper the show is definitely
preoccupied with that decades surface
level aesthetic there's the fashion the
toys the technology the public Spaces by
saturating itself with all of the
dressings of the 80s the show fully
makes use of its period setting albeit
in a way that often isn't relevant to
the actual plot its focus on children
and adolescents also makes it right for
some of the strongest pop culture
associations of the 1980s as marketing
Scholars William J havelena and Susan L
holic note we tend to have the strongest
nostalgic associations with media and
pop culture from our adolescents which
is presumably true for the Gen xers and
older Millennials who form a sizable
chunk of Netflix's audience and each
moment in the 80s of stranger things is
filled with all of the cool stuff we
associate with a decade creating an
idealized version that all of us can
Pine for and you could argue this
idealism has grown stronger each season
season 2 gave us a Gremlins riff with
Dustin and dart and the whole small town
kids fight Shady invading Russians thing
in season 3 is straight up Red Dawn this
left season 4 feeling disjointed in its
potpourri of genre tropes lurching from
zany spielbergian comedy to a Silence of
the Lamb's rip-off by overtly mirroring
movies in its cinematography and
narrative the show is engaged Aging in
some good old-fashioned intertextuality
or in other words it's creating a
relationship by mapping itself onto an
already existing work with the same tone
when Robin and Nancy's visit with an
accused serial killer reminds us so
vividly of Silence of the Lambs we're
reminded how we felt when we first saw
Anthony Hopkins creep it up and it puts
us in that headspace no Chianti required
an intertextuality engages with
nostalgic media in a specific way
scholar Frederick Jameson OBS that in an
age of remakes and nostalgic
oversaturation intertextuality displaces
Real History by substituting fact for
aesthetic style or pseudo-history he
writes that the Nostalgia film was never
a matter of some old-fashioned
representation of historical content but
instead approached the past through
stylistic connotation conveying pastness
by the glossy qualities of the image
referencing the media of the past rather
than the actual history is the priority
but not everyone watching stranger
things today was even alive in the 80s
so what are they experiencing when they
indulge in this virtual reconstruction
of the decade a little something scholar
Arjuna Padre calls armchair Nostalgia or
airsoft's Nostalgia that is Nostalgia
without lived experience or Collective
historical memory in his criticism of
nostalgia tinged advertising and
Merchandising which stranger things has
done its fair share of a pottery argues
that such media creates Nostalgia for
things that never were this image
imagine Nostalgia thus inverts the
temporal logic of fantasy and creates
much deeper wants than simple Envy
imitation or greed could by themselves
invite interestingly enough a lot of
young people's Nostalgia for the world
depicted in stranger things is actually
based on Nostalgia for the 1980s movies
that they watched in their youth which
defined that decade in their minds thus
a pseudo-history is born and that's the
thing about pseudo history it erases
some of the uglier truths of the time
period depicted sure early seasons of
stranger things are hardly all fun and
games there's a genuine darkness that
underscores it from the get-go most
obviously The Disappearance of a cute
kid but that darkness is defined by an
unambiguous evil rendering the conflict
that ensues almost childlike in its
Simplicity there's no empathizing with
the demogorgon no matter what your
fondness or Venus fly traps may be mind
flayer is more of the same in this way
the darkness of the upside down in the
first two seasons of the show threatens
the essential lightness of the world
above and that threat only escalates as
future Seasons attempt to complicate the
balance now there's a strong case to to
be made that season three of stranger
things marked a turning point for the
show's relationship with Nostalgia as it
became less about reveling in the
commercial Delights of 1980s youth
culture and ventured closer to critique
obviously there's still plenty of
production designed to make you Pine for
the 80s half the freaking season is set
at a shopping mall after all but we
learned that the mall isn't all fun in
games it's a sign of reagan-era
corporatization that's displacing tons
of long-standing mom and pop shops when
intern Nancy points this out to the
local newspaper though it's brushed off
as a matter of course unremarkable in
pro-business Reagan Era America
what's more unlike the earlier ambient
Nostalgia this season's narrative
revolves around real anxieties from the
80s most notably you have the Cold War
and the ussr's Army plays a key role as
the Show's first real human antagonist
they want to use the upside down to Aid
their Cold War agenda they set up camp
in a giant lab beneath Hawkins STAR
Court Mall with the help of a colluding
power hungry mayor who puts on a
patriotic fare while facilitating a
communist Invasion the Cold War paranoia
about a covert Russian infiltration
aided and abetted by politicians is thus
realized as well as Cold War era
anxieties that the Soviets would use
mind control to turn Americans into Kami
zombies and though there's plenty of fun
to be had it's arguably using Nostalgia
for mildly darker purposes than it has
before by making these elements Central
to the narrative stranger things is
seemingly acknowledging that the 80s
might not really have been as simple and
chill as its portrayal led us to believe
surprise it marks a deliberate effort to
engage with the reality of the decade
which was not just one big game of
Dungeons and Dragons but while season 3
tried to address darker aspects of the
time it didn't really pull it off in
theory the way stranger things
integrates issues like corporatization
and Cold War anxieties remove some of
the show's rose-tinted nehbete but it
also introduces an element of whiplash
that undermines its own premise Nancy's
Newsroom critique of corporatization is
quickly overshadowed by all the fun
Antics enjoyed at the mall and when it
comes to the Cold War narrative the show
ultimately settles for Simplicity over
complexity resolving nuanced real world
issues by blaming everything on the
spooky unambiguously evil Russians and
their monster friends this Invasion
obviously as we noted draws pretty
explicitly from the film Red Dawn
invoking the same happy Nostalgia that
it does for those of us who watched
Spielberg films in the 90s by letting us
Revel in the intertextuality we can
immediately conclude that the kids are
going to triumph over evil
intertextuality strikes again maybe the
show was trying to critique that brand
of feverish Cold War era American Media
but if so it doesn't really signpost
that intention mostly it depicts the
cold war with a false sense of
Simplicity just as warm and fuzzy
Nostalgia suggests a desirable
Simplicity of its own
so in trying to critique its 80s setting
season 3 still seems to conclude that
the time was simpler than the present
day but if season 3 tried and failed to
critique Hades Nostalgia then season 4
arguably Embraces Nuance in order to
further its commentary on Nostalgia at
large the most obvious way it does so is
by invoking the satanic Panic a real
world 80s moral Panic which sparked
fears that things like Dungeons and
Dragons or heavy metal music were
leading kids to worship Satan or like do
ritual murders not coincidentally both
of those things were enjoyed by social
outcasts and non-conformists this added
to the stigma and authorizing of folks
who were already rendered pariahs by the
conservative social norms of the decade
this was after all an arrow that looked
back quite fondly on the ramp and
Conformity of the 50s and this clearly
applies to our protagonist who are prime
examples of this sort of other ring
previously we had seen our Plucky
adolescent friends being bullied or
excluded but this is the first real
sense we get that non-conformity in
reagan-era America wasn't just socially
unadvisable it was potentially criminal
as plenty of folks convicted of dubious
charges during the satanic Panic could
tell you and whether it's for their
interests or their Identity or their
mental health issues stranger things
asks us to care about folks who are in
danger of 80s style societal scorn in a
subversive twist it is only The
Outsiders who are able to believe the
truth that a Dungeons and dragon style
monster is on the hunt in Hawkins
meanwhile the Ducks and cops all lead to
the conclusion that the freak Eddie
Munson is responsible for the murders
and during other moments on the show
some of the trappings of the 80s that
might have once been celebrated become
dark and troubling like 11's horrible
day at the roller skating rink where a
colorful fun retro Trope turns
completely haunting
but arguably the show's best exploration
of The Perils of nostalgia is in its
preoccupation with trauma and mental
health struggles we know lots of people
have been talking about this but we
think it's worth diving deeper as we
examine whether the show can
successfully subvert its own Nostalgia
most relevantly there's Hopper's
backstory which we finally learn like so
many men of the era his guilt and
substance abuse issues were rooted in
Trauma from his service in Vietnam ever
since I was 18.
there's some letter of induction in the
mail Uncle Sam wants me to go fight some
war in the jungle we learned
specifically that he was assigned to the
agent orange division ostensibly an
herbicide to remove Vietnamese Defenders
tactical Edge in the jungle agent orange
was also super toxic causing widespread
disability and birth defects the U.S
troops assigned to the agent orange Corp
were kept in the dark as to its true
nature and many suffered its effects
followed us clone to us Hopper blames
himself for his daughter's cancer and
for not warning his wife about the risks
caused by his exposure we had a baby and
she was um
she was born healthy she's perfect you
know Sarah
and then she died his resulting descent
into substance abuse mirrors the
experience of many Vietnam War veterans
many struggled with PTSD or other mental
health troubles or were denied social
services or even ended up unhoused here
we see that not everything about the 80s
is something to be nostalgic for coupled
with the very real brutality of life in
a Soviet Gulag we also see the darker
less cartoonish reality of the Cold War
then more abstractly there's El season
Arc which sees her literally reliving
her younger life under the care of Papa
and this serves as a good reminder that
not everyone would be stoked to return
to their childhood and in some of the
season's most powerful scenes we watch
as she delves into her most horrific
memories of a massacre at the lab the
pain of reliving her trauma feels equal
and opposite to the nostalgic Joy
viewers might have felt reliving their
own 80s childhoods real or imagined in
the earlier Seasons the trauma that Elle
has spent so long blocking from her
memory feels completely oppositional to
the whole idea of nostalgia that the
show was rooted in and it's probably the
best example of the show's evolving
maturity of course trauma has always
undergirded stranger things whether in
will struggles to get back to real life
after his time in the upside down or L's
ongoing flashbacks about being separated
from her mother but by focusing on it
throughout the season the show was
taking what was subtext and making it
central to the plot it's symptomatic of
stranger things slow descent into a
darker world view it's been slowly
peeling back its own Nostalgia like an
onion to reveal the real trauma that
lingers under even the happiest memories
of 80's childhood and because we'd come
to love the characters as tropes from
80s films it takes us by surprise when
the show actually stops to examine their
pain and that examination and the growth
that comes with it subverts are
ultimately nostalgic view of them it
serves as a strong reminder that looking
backwards as a person or as a nation can
be as painful as it is joyous stranger
things seems to be Earnest in its
attempts at critiquing Nostalgia But
ultimately these efforts lead to a sort
of internal conflict of interest because
alongside say Hopper's discussion of his
time in Vietnam we still have the same
nostalgic callbacks the series was
originally beloved for that's
understandable Their audience has come
to expect as much from the show but it
still creates a kind of cognitive
dissonance in fact in this season the
show even goes kind of meta with its
Nostalgia featuring new flashbacks to
past beloved moments from earlier in the
series this creates a sort of double
Nostalgia for us a Nostalgia of
remembering our first time watching the
show you could argue that this is a way
for the creators to demonstrate just how
much things have changed but arguably it
skirts the edge of fan service the
darker that stranger things goes the
more these twin threads of celebratory
Nostalgia and critique of nostalgia
start to chafe together so In Sum we'd
argue that stranger things can't really
subvert the very same Nostalgia it
actively invokes you can't have your
Nostalgia cake and critique it too and
let's face it the show's Thrills and
Spills escapism is why we all got hooked
to begin with if season one had ground
to a halt to explore Joyce buyers
experience of single working-class
motherhood would we have kept watching
there's not much room in the Whimsical
spielbergian Paradigm for examining the
the full on complexity of real world
politics or the nuanced and highly
subjective effects that they have on us
as human beings but it can do compelling
character work and we'd argue that
season 4 was the best example of that so
stranger things mostly remains a show
that creates intertextual Nostalgia to
make its audience remember or pretend
they remember the 80s and if it happens
to do so to commercial ends then all the
better to merchandise the [ __ ] out of 11
right that's the story and Gary cross
puts it all nostalges consist of
organizers and participants but today
the organizers increasingly are
marketers and participants are consumers
that is to say being nostalgic for an
era naturally makes you more likely to
buy [ __ ] that reminds you of that era
hey let he who lives in a glass house
cast the first Walkman but this type of
nostalgia has a potentially more
Insidious side too the imagined past
like those invoked in the show are also
used to fuel a political Nostalgia that
has real-world consequences like a right
wing yearning for a pass for America was
a Place full of faith family and
straight people who own guns or the
liberal Nostalgia for a world of
Tolerance and ethical capitalism in both
cases this Nostalgia functionally
distracts us from critically evaluating
the present it convinces us that the
only way forwards is backwards it might
not be a big deal when this inspires us
to say buy a two liter of Coke with our
Pizza Hut but it can potentially be
harmful when it starts to shape our
political reality luckily stranger
things seems content to stay out of the
pesky boring politics that constitute
adult life at least for now but what do
you think the stranger things succeed at
critiquing The Nostalgia that it's based
in or was season 4 of failed lab
experiment let us know in the comments
thanks to our patrons for all their
support and don't miss out on our new
patreon perks and remember you can join
us every Thursday for our weekly live
stream throw fireworks at that subscribe
button like you're a vanquishing an
interdimensional monster and don't
forget to ring that Bell as always
thanks for watching and good luck making
that deal with God later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you